the capitals northern suburbs are under
attack the skyline's increasingly
clouded after rocket strikes
the russian military's trying to push
closer into the city but they've got to
get through three small communities in
between
we're rushed through checkpoints the
shells land here without warning causing
fires which rip through this forested
area
and in lutus they know they're the ones
now holding the line against the
russians so they're digging trenches
and bolstering their positions
the community's already been hit several
times
the attacks have left yet more people
without homes
and workplaces and businesses have been
left shattered
but the main supermarket is still
operating despite being shelled earlier
the staff are just wiping down their
supplies and carrying on regardless
we even know how to protect ourselves if
something is incoming she says we lie
down and cover our heads
a lot of the fridges and storage areas
are damaged the constant volley of
attacks has seen half the town empty the
other half can't understand why this is
happening
they've attacked our houses our schools
our shops she said they're hurting us
too much for what please someone explain
nadia shows us the crater that's been
left in her back garden parts of the
rocket still visible
god loves me she says i can't believe
i'm alive
inside her house she shows us how almost
every room is affected with the ceiling
down and windows shattered
she lives alone with her 81 year old
mother who's clearly unsettled
granny was born during the second world
war nadia explains about her mother now
she has to survive another
her mother and her have been here all
their lives leaving is inconceivable
and for those who've lived through this
all before the war has awful
her daughter interrupts children are
dying women are dying she says this
isn't just war this is destroying this
is genocide of the people they're just
killing us to eliminate us they want to
remove us from the surface of the land
so they see their defense of these
northern suburbs as critical
and the sounds of russians nearby seems
constant whilst we're here
they're nazis he says
and there's another attack
he waits to hear if it's landing close
by
he was a swimming coach a few weeks ago
now everyone here is a bombing expert
the man taking us into their bunker was
a tv producer now part of the army
keeping the foreign troops outside the
capital how will they be able to get
inside keith do you think
[Music]
no they cannot capture keep he says they
can try to surround it but if they try
to enter they'll face very heavy
resistance
and helping them is leon from chichester
who came to kiev on his motorbike and
went straight to the front line i
thought to myself
how could i not do something about this
how can i not go out there and help
especially seeing the war crimes being
committed on civilian populations i just
thought that i can't can't sit by and
let this happen
he's standing shoulder to shoulder with
the ukrainian volunteers helping out as
a medic and now defending kiev
they've got mannequins at the entrance
of lutisch to try to confuse any russian
snipers the residents inside here know
this could be a long drawn out and
bloody war alex crawford sky news in the
northern outskirts of kiev